nuevamente las manifestaciones civiles
se apoderan de Israel en el marco del
día de la igualdad cientos de personas
se mostraron en contra de la Reforma
judicial que impulsa el Primer Ministro
Benjamín la cual fue paralizada en marzo
pero que desde hace días fue retomado
por la kenneses la nueva legislación le
daría más autoridad a judíos ultra
ortodoxos en el poder quien extienden a
beneficiar más a los hombres con sus
decisiones
Bueno nos estamos manifestando por los
derechos de las mujeres en Israel
tenemos miedo de que con el nuevo
régimen y con las nuevas leyes que se
van a aplicar la situación de las
mujeres vaya a empeorar y por eso
estamos aquí Hoy no queremos que Israel
se convierta en Irán
[Música]
las extensiones e instituciones
religiosas y el permiso judíos Ultra
ortodoxos para que no realicen el
servicio militar son otros puntos que
molestaron a los civiles
estamos aquí para protestar por todo eso
y dejarle muy claro al presidente
israelí que no vamos a dejarlo pasar sin
protestar vamos a hacer lo que sea
necesario para que Israel tenga plena
igualdad para todos los ciudadanos
dentro del país
la Reforma impulsada por el gobierno
ultraderechista israelí zanjó profundas
de diferencias dentro de la sociedad
porque beneficiarían y tenía en las
causas de corrupción que enfrentan
además de ejercer control en los jueces
del supremo